[Music]
it's over
they're all gone bank it's time it's
time you say what happened
[Music]
Rick want you to meet my cousin Russell
Bufalino better watch this as well as
tough guys around here did he tell you
I'm not afraid of crazy life he thinks I
was one of a thousand working stiffs I
thought it wasn't no more you got a good
friend here you don't know how good a
friend you got Russell he took a shine
to me right away after a while he
started giving me little things to do I
know you read a lot of things about me I
just want to say I'm sorry I know I
wasn't that good dad I know that I know
what I was just trying to protect Ali's
from what you didn't see what I see what
I've been through a friend of ours is
having a little trouble friend at the
top Oh your friend cuz it's Jimmy off
nice to meet you
you want to be a part of this fight a
part of this history whatever you need
me to do I'm available
only three people in the world and one
of these and only one of them is Irish
you know strong I made you I know things
they don't know why no he said that you
sure he said that I'm worried
nobody threatens offer records I got
tapes they're done
I had to put you into stand later
everybody put here as a date when he's
gonna go
I know how you feel fine trust me I know
I'll bring you back after get euchre
yeah
[Music]
you